never let anyone tell you that a story's
already been told
yeah that's a fun one um
it goes back to
being a bull in a china shop as a writer
that
your attack as a storyteller is so key
to succeeding as a writer
um lazy writing
limp writing it's
it's often so forgettable and
the key word in the entertainment
industry is outrageousness people
go to the movies or watch a tv show or
go to the theater
to see something extraordinary
something different something energizing
something fun
or exciting or meaningful or
cathartic so
[Music]
it has to do with
a rebellious streak
where
you know many people have heard the
saying
there's nothing new under the sun every
story's been told
there's only seven basic stories or
three basic stories or whatever
and part of me completely understands
that
and part of me that just pisses me off
it's like you know
you can't tell me that i can't come up
with something
that that you've never seen that will it
just it's like waving a red flag in
front of a bull
it it just makes me mad and
it brings out the attack in me and
the desire to shatter people's
expectations and blow people's minds and
take them where they've never been and
just violate their expectations violate
my own storytelling rut
you know it's you know think of a movie
like being john malkovich
you know it's like so off the beaten
track
and i'm sure there was somebody
telling the writer oh you shouldn't do
that that's not how stories
go it's like it's just
weak and it's it's
such a lack of adventure and a lack of
courage and
and just you know one of my favorite
terms is attack as a storyteller
how much attack do you bring to the
table what
what are the ways that you can dazzle an
audience take them on a ride that
they've never been on and if you accept
the idea that you can't possibly come up
with something
that nobody's ever seen
then it
kind of takes the wind out of your sails
in a certain way it says you're you're
not all that creative you can't come up
with something it's like i
i refuse to play that way
i go the other end of the spectrum i
always want to
know what are the extremes in any story
idea
just to see what they are
you often you know you'll find yourself
if you're
trying to solve a story problem where
you've got to figure out a specific
thing in a story
where there's kind of a normal set of
possibilities
and then there's unusual possibilities
and then there's extreme possibilities
and like for instance the coen brothers
say that if somebody can figure out
our next move if they had a week to
figure it out and they can figure it out
in a week
we're not going to use it they go way
above and beyond
shaking up your expectations
violating your expectations if
you're trying to solve a story problem
and you have
a selection of possibilities for ways
you could get out of that situation or
whatever
one of the things i've found is really
fun
is is to not only look at the extremes
because it gets you out of the stock
choices in the ordinary
but what i also want to know just out of
pure curiosity
is what's the single craziest
possibility
in the whole universe for that
particular choice what it's like
wildly crazy and usually it won't work
at
all but sometimes you'd be like well
that's interesting if i backed it down a
few notches it could start to
fit into my arena and it's really fresh
and different
and takes the story in a different
direction and
shakes up the character and
every once in a while that single
craziest idea
works brilliantly in a completely
unexpected way
i've had that happen to me where i said
well what's the single craziest idea and
it would be like
well it would be that and it'd be like
whoa i
never would have thought of that and i'm
using that it's great so it's
that's part of attack as a storyteller
just going for it and
not just stretching the envelope
envelope but
you know obliterating it and just having
fun you know it's
writing's fun but you're using analogies
similar to war and so or combat in some
way is is going
facing the the page every day like
combat
it's a good question because
it depends in many ways on who you are
because if you are
someone with the martial arts skills of
bruce lee
say then you get into
the ring with pretty much any fighter
you can figure something out so it's
so it's not like god i don't know what
i'm gonna do i'm staring at the blank
page
it's like no i can i can make this work
you know this guy weighs 600 pounds so i
got to figure something out
but you know bruce lee is going to bring
a lot of stuff to the table
so the more skill you have as a
storyteller
and as a scriptwriter as a dramatist
the less intimidated you are
by a normal array of writing challenges
now you really
want to get in over your head if it's
all too easy then you're not
doing your job right so
like if i'm starting in on a script and
it starts to get
complex and deep part of my brain goes
uh-oh we're getting in over our my head
here
and the other part of my brain goes yeah
that's that's good that's where you want
to be
and they say that writers are like show
horses
they're not happy unless they're trying
to jump over something that could kill
them
and i was thinking about that last night
and i found an actually much better
analogy
is that writers are like extreme
rock climbers or something they're not
happy climbing something
unless it could well kill them if it's
too less of a challenge they're like
they're bored that's they get their
adrenaline
from the fact that nobody's ever climbed
this cliff and they're doing with no
ropes
and they're hanging by you know like two
fingers on a
piece of rock that big and they're like
this is fun
this is life and they don't want to do
anything else
they even found that the like the combat
nurses and medics who came back from
vietnam
couldn't go back to a normal job it was
too i can't sit in a corner and file
papers
so they ended up as like emergency room
physicians and
you know frontline cops are like they
had to be in
in the deep stuff to because it was it
didn't cut it anymore for them
so the more craft
you bring to the table the less
intimidated you are by the material
but you also want to be
in over your head they said that bob
marley who grew up
on the water when they got bored he and
his brother would swim out to sea as far
as they could
until they were completely exhausted and
then they'd try to make it back to shore
that was their idea of like a fun
afternoon
so it's kind of like that it's like the
material
should challenge you but you should also
be
throwing hand grenades into your own
story ideas to make your job harder
to challenge yourself so that like a
rock climber is like i'm not going to
take that safe route i'm going to do
this
dangerous route over here that nobody's
ever done before
and it may well kill me but i can't live
without that level of challenge
so i'm not sure if that answered your
question exactly
i think it does i think that basically
you're saying you need to be
stimulated but not bored and it can't be
too easy
and so it's kind of like playing chess a
hobbyist playing chess
with an expert versus a hobbyist playing
chess with another hobbyist
right and that
the the more substantial your craft as a
writer
the less it seems like how can i
possibly do this
you know it's a job it's a story and
of course it's challenging and it's hard
but like bruce lee
facing whatever opponent he's like
i may get my ass kicked but i know what
i'm doing and i can take this on
you know i'm it's not like what am i
going to do what am i going to do it's
like no i know exactly what i'm going to
do
i just have to figure out how to do it
for this particular thing
you